Daniel Friedman: Hello and welcome. It's Active Inference
guest stream number 51.1 on July 28,
2023. We are here with Tomaso Salvatore
and we will be having a presentation and
a discussion on the recent work Causal
Inference via Predictive Coding. So
thanks so much for joining. For those
who are watching Live, feel free to
write questions in the live chat and off
to you. Thank you.
Tommaso Salvatori: Thank you very much, Daniel, for
inviting me. Always been a big fan
of the channel and I've been watching a
lot of videos, so I'm quite excited to
be here and be the one speaking this
time. So I'm going to talk about this
recent preprint that I put out, which
has been the work of the last couple of
months. And it's a collaboration
with Luca Binketti, Amin,
Mccarrak Berenmille and Thomas
Lukasiavic. And it's basically
a joint work between Verses, which is
the company I work for, the University
of Oxford and Teovien.
So during this
talk,
this is basically the outline of the
talk, I will start talking about what
predictive coding is and give an
introduction of what it is, a brief
historical introduction, why I think
it's important to study predictive
coding, even, for example, from the
machine learning perspective. I will
then provide a small intro to what
causal inference is. And once
we have all those informations together,
I will then discuss why I wrote this
paper, what was basically the research
question that inspired me and the other
collaborators and present
the main results, which are how
to perform inference so intervention and
counterfactual inference, and how to
learn the causal structures from a
given data set using predictive coding.
And then I will of course conclude with
some small summary and some
discussion on why I believe this work
can be impactful and some future
directions.
So what is predative coding? predative
coding is in general famous for being a
neuroscience inspired learning method.
So a theory of how information
processing in the brain works and
brain, formally speaking, the theory of
creative coding can be described as
basically having a hierarchical
structure of neurons in the brain.
And you have two different families of
neurons in the brain. The first family
is the one in charging of sending
prediction information. So neurons in a
specific level of the hierarchy send
information and predict the activity
of the level below. And the second
family of neuron is that of error
neurons. And the error neurons, they
send prediction error information up the
hierarchy. So one level predicts the
activity of the level below.
This prediction has some mismatch which
was actually going on in the level
below, and information about the
prediction error gets sent up the
hierarchy. However,
predictive coding was actually not
burned as a neuroscience,
as a theory from the neurosciences, but
it was actually initially developed as a
method for signal processing and
compression back in the 50s. So the work
of Oliver Elias, which are actually
contemporary of Shannon
they realized that once we have a
predictor, a model that works that is
well in predicting data, sending
messages about the error in those
predictions is actually much cheaper
than sending the entire message every
time. And this is how predictive coding
was born. So as a signal processing
and compression mechanism in information
theory back in the 50s, it was
actually in the 80s that
exactly the same model was used in
neuroscience with
the work from Mumford or other works
that, for example, explain how the
Retina process information. So we get
prediction signals from the outside
world and we need to compress this
representation and have this internal
representation in our neurons. And the
method is very similar, if not
equivalent to the one that was developed
by Elias and Oliver in the 50s.
Maybe what's the biggest paradigm shift
happened in 99 thanks to the work of
Rao and Ballard in which they
introduced this concept that I mentioned
earlier about hierarchical structures in
the brain where prediction information
is top down and error information is
bottom up. And something that they did
that wasn't done before is that they
explain and develop this theory about
not only inference, but also about how
learning works in the brain. So it's
also a theory of how our synapses get
updated. And the last big
breakthrough that I'm going to talk
about in this brief historical
introduction is from 2003.
But then he kept going in the
years after, thanks to Karl Friston, in
which basically he took the theory
of Rowan Ballard and he developed, he
extended it and generalized it to the
theory of generative models. So
basically the main claim that Karl
Frieston did is that predictive coding
is an evidence maximization scheme of a
specific kind of generative model,
which I'm going to introduce later as
well. So to make a
brief summary, in the first two kinds
of predica described so signal
processing and compression and
information processing in the Retina and
in the brain in general, they are
inference methods. And the biggest
change, the biggest revolution that we
had in 1999, so let's say in the 21st
century, is apparative coding was seen
as a learning algorithm. So we can first
compress information and then update all
the synapses or all the latent variables
that we have in our generative model to
improve our generative model itself.
So let's give some definitions
that are a little bit more formal. So
prior coding can be seen as a
hierarchical Gaussian generative model.
So here is a very simple figure in which
we have this hierarchical structure
which can be as deep as we want.
And prediction signals go
from one latent variable XN to the
following one and it gets transformed
every time via function GN or
GI.
This is a generative model, as I said.
And what's the marginal probability of
this generative model? Well, it's simply
the probability of the last can
you see my cursor? Yes. Right? Yes.
Perfect. So it's the generative model of
the last vertex is the probability
distribution of the last vertex times
the probability distribution of every
other vertex conditioned on the activity
of the vertex before or on the latent
variable before.
I earlier said that it's a Gaussian
generative model, which means that those
probabilities, they are in Gaussian form
and every and those function g
in general and especially since, for
example, in Rambalar paper and in all
the papers that came afterwards. Also
because of the deep learning revolution,
those functions are simply linear maps
or nonlinear maps with activation
functions or nonlinear maps with
activation function and an additive
bias.
So we can give an
informal definition of creative coding
and we can say predictive coding is an
inversion scheme for such a generative
model where its model evidence is
maximized by minimizing a quantity that
is called a variation of free energy.
In general, the goal of every generative
model is to maximize model evidence,
but this quantity is always intractable.
And we have some techniques that allow
us to approximate this solution and the
one that we use in pritef coding instead
of minimizing aberration of free energy,
which is a lower bound of the model
evidence in this work and actually in
a lot of other ones. So it's the
standard way of doing it. This
minimization is performed via gradient
descent and yes,
performed via gradient descent. And
there are actually other methods such as
expectation maximization which is often
equivalent. Or you can use some other
message passing algorithms such as
belief propagation, for example,
and going a little bit back in time.
So forgetting a little bit about the
statistical generative models, we can
see pref coding,
I said already a couple of times as a
hierarchical model with neural
activities. So with neurons, latent
variables that represent neural
activities, the sender signal down the
hierarchy and with error nodes or error
neurons, the sender signal up the
hierarchy so they send the error
information back. What's the variation
of free energy of these class operative
coding models? It's simply the sum of
the mean square error of all the error
neurons, so is the sum of
the total error squared.
And this representation is going to be
useful in the later slides and in how
I'm going to explain how to use pref
coding to model causal inference. For
example, why do you think pre tip coding
is important and is a nice algorithm to
study? Well, first of all, as I said
earlier, it optimizes the correct
objective which is the model evidence or
marginal likelihood. And then
it does so by optimizing a lower bound
which is called the rational free
energy, as I said. And the rational free
energy is interesting because it can be
written as a sum of two different terms
which are and each of those term
optimizing. It has important impacts,
for example, in machine learning tasks
or in general in learning tasks. So one
of those term forces memorization. So
the second term basically forces the
model to fit a specific data set and the
first term forces the model to minimize
the complexity. And as we know, for
example from the Occam's razor theory,
if we have two different models that
perform similarly on a specific training
set, the one that we have to get and the
one that is expected to generalize the
most is the less complex one. So
updating generative model via
vibrational free energy allows us to
basically converge to the optimal Occam
razor model which both memorizes a
data set but is also able to generalize
very well on unsigned data points.
A second reason of why prioritic coding
is important is that it actually doesn't
have to be defined on a hierarchical
structure, but it can be modeled on more
complex and flexible architectures such
as directed graphical model with any
shape or generalized even more to
networks with a lot of cycles that
resemble brain region. And the
underlying reason is that you're not
learning and predicting with a forward
pass and then back propagating the error
but you're minimizing an energy function
and this allows basically every kind of
hierarchy to be allows
to go behind hierarchies and allow to
learn cycles. And this is actually quite
important because the brain is full of
cycles as we have some information from
some recent papers that managed
to map completely the brain of some
animals such as fruit fly. The brain is
full of cycles so it makes sense to
train our machine learning models or our
models in general with an algorithm that
allows us to train using cyclic
structures. The third reason why
prior coding is interesting is that it
has been formally proven that it is more
robust than standard neural networks
during with back propagation. So if you
have a neural network and you want to
perform classification tasks,
creative coding is more robust.
And this is interesting in tasks
such as online learning, training of
small data sets or continuous learning
tasks. And the theory basically comes
from the fact that imperative coding has
been proved to approximate implicit
gradient descent, which is a different
version of the explicit gradient descent
which is the standard gradient descent
used in every single model basically.
And it's a variation that is more robust
I think. Okay, I did quite a long intro
to predictive coding, I think. I'm now
moving to the second topic which is
causal inference. And what's
causal inference? Causal inference is a
very general theory that has been
formalized the most by Judea Pearl.
He's definitely the most important
person in the field of causal inference.
He wrote some very nice books. For
example, the Book of Why is highly
recommended if you want to learn more
about this topic and it basically
tackles the following problem so let's
assume we have a joint probability
distribution which is associated with a
Bayesian network. This is going to be a
little bit the running example through
all the paper, especially with
Bayesian networks of this shape.
Those Bayesian networks, the variables
inside, they can represent different
quantities. So for example, a Bayesian
network with this shape can represent
the quantities on the right. So,
socioeconomical statue of an individual,
its education level, its intelligence
and its income level,
something the classical statistics is
very good at and its wild,
most used application is to model
observations or correlations. A
correlation basically answer the
question what is D if we observe another
variable C? So for example, in this
case, what's the income level, the
expected income level of an individual
if I observe his education level and
of course, if that person has
a higher degree of education, for
example a master or PhD. I'm expecting
general that person to have a higher
income level and this is a correlation.
However, sometimes there are things that
are very hard to observe, but they play
a huge role in determining those
quantities. So for example, it could be
that the income level is much, much more
defined by the intelligence of a
specific person and maybe
that the intelligence. So if a person is
intelligent, he's also most likely to
have a higher education level. But still
the real reason why the income is high
is because of the IQ.
And this cannot be studied by Simplico
relations and has to be studied by a
more advanced technique which is called
an intervention. An intervention
basically answers the question is what
is D if we change C to a specific value?
So for example, we can take an
individual and check his income level
and then change its education level. So
intervene on this word and change his
education level without touching his
intelligence and see how much its income
changes. For example, if the income
changes a lot it means that the
intelligence doesn't play a big role in
this, but the education level does. If
the income level doesn't change much,
it means that maybe there's a hidden
variable in this case the intelligence
that determines the income level of a
person. The third
quantity important in causal inference
is that of counterfactuals. So for
example, a counterfactual answers the
question what would D be had we
changed C to a different value in the
past? So for example, we can see that
the difference between interventions and
counterfactuals is that interventions
act in the future. So I'm intervening in
the world now to observe a change in the
future while counterfactuals allow us to
go back in time and change a variable
back in time and see how that change
would have influenced the world we live
in now. And those are defined
by Judeoperl as the three levels of
causal inference. Correlation is the
first level, intervention is the second
level and counterfactual is the third
level.
What are interventions? I'm going to
define them more formally now that I
gave an intuitive definition and I'm
using this notation here, which is the
same actually throughout all the
presentation. So x is always going to be
a latent variable, si is always going to
be a data point or an observation, and
VI is always going to be a vertex. So
every time you see VI, we are only
interested in the structure of the
graph, for example. So let's assume we
have a Bayesian model which has the same
structure as the Bayesian model
we saw in the previous slide. Given that
x three is equal to s three, this is the
observation we make statistics allows us
to compute the probability or the
expectation of x four, which is the
latent variable related to this vertex.
Given that x three is equal to s three,
to perform an intervention we need a new
kind of notation which is called the do
operation. So in this case,
x four, we want to compute the
probability of x four, given the fact
that we intervene in the word and change
x three to x three. And how do we do
this to perform an intervention? Judy
Perl tells us that we have to have an
intermediate step before computing a
correlation is that first we have to
remove all the incoming edges to v
three. So we have to study not
this Bayesian network, but the second
one. And then at this point we
are allowed to compute a correlation as
we normally do. And this is
an intervention. A counterfactual
is a generalization of this that, as I
said, lived in the past, and they're
computing using structural causal
models. A structural causal model is a
Tuplet which is conceptually similar to
a Bayesian network. But basically we
have this new class of variables on top,
which are the unobservable variables
they use. So we have the Bayesian
network that we had before, x one, x
two, x three, x four. But we also have
those unobservable or variables
that depend on the environment. You
cannot control them, you can infer them,
but they are there.
And F is a set of functions that
depends on all the basically,
F of x of x three depends on x one
because you have an arrow, on x two
because you have an arrow, and on the
unobservable variable that also
influences x three.
So yes, intuitively you can
think of a structural causal model as a
Bayesian network with those unobservable
variables on top, and each unobservable
variable only influences its
own latent variable x. So for example,
IU will never touch x one as well, u
three will only touch U three, u one
will only influence x one, and so forth
and so on.
So performing counterfactual inference
answers the following question so what
would x four be at x three being equal
to another variable in a past situation
u. And computing this
counterfactual requires three different
steps. So abduction is
the computation of all the background
variables. So in this step we want to go
back in time and understand how the
environment, the unobservable
environment was in that specific moment
in time. And we do this by fixing
all the latent variables x to some
specific data that we already have and
performing this inference on the use.
Then we're going to use the U to keep
the U that we have learned and perform
an intervention. So a counterfactual
can also be seen as an intervention back
in time in which we know the environment
variables u one, U two and U four in
that specific moment.
And what's the missing step?
So what would x four be at x three being
equal to another data point in
that specific situation? Now we can
compute a correlation and the
correlation we do it on the graph
in which we have already performed an
intervention using the environment
variables that we have learned in the
abduction step. And this is a
counterfactual inference.
This is the last slide of the causal
inference introduction and it's about
structured learning. Basically
everything I've said so far relies on
the fact that we know the causal
dependencies among the data points. So
we know the structure of the graph, we
know which variable influences which
one, we know the arrows in general but
in practice this is actually not always
possible. So we
don't have access to the causal graph
most of the times and actually learning
the best causal graph from data is still
an open problem. We are improving in
this, we are getting better. But how to
perform this task exactly is
still an open problem. So as I said,
basically the goal is to infer causal
relationships from observational data.
So given a data set we want to infer the
directed icyclic graph that describes
the connectivity between the system and
the variables of the data set. So for
example, here we have an example that I
guess we are all familiar with because
of the pandemic. So we have those four
variables age, vaccine,
hospitalization and city.
And we want to infer the causal
dependencies among those variables. So
for example, we want to learn directly
from data that the probability of a
person being hospitalized depends on its
age and on the fact whether it's
vaccinated or not and so forth and so
on.
So this is the end of the long
introduction but I hope it was clear
enough and I hope that I gave the basics
to understand basically the results of
the paper and now we can go to the
research questions. So the research
questions are the following first I want
to see whether predictive coding can be
used to perform causal inference. So
predictive coding so far has only been
used to perform to compute correlations
in Bayesian networks. And the big
question is can we go beyond correlation
and model intervention and
counterfactual in a biological plausible
way? So in a way
that it's for example, simple,
intuitive and allow us to only play with
the neurons and not touch, for example,
the huge structure of the graph and
more in practice. More specifically,
the question becomes can we define
operative coding based structural causal
model to perform interventions and
counterfactuals? The second question
is, as I said, that having a
structure causal model assumes that we
know the structure of the Bayesian
network, so it assumes that
we have the arrows. Can we go beyond
this and use predictive coding networks
to learn the causal structure of the
graph?
Basically, giving positive answers to
both those questions would allow us to
use predictive coding as an end to end
causal inference method which basically
takes a data set and allow us to test
interventions and counterfactual
predictions directly from this data set.
So let's tackle the first problem.
So causal inference Vibrative coding
which is also the section that gives the
title to the paper basically. And here I
will show how to perform correlations
with Abrasive coding which is already
known, and how to perform interventional
queries which I think is the real
question of the paper.
So here is a causal graph which is the
usual graph that we had and
here is the corresponding priority
coding model. So the axes are the latent
variables and correspond to the neurons
in a neural network model.
And the black arrow pass prediction
information from one neuron to the one
down the hierarchy. And every vertex
also has this error neuron which passes
information up the hierarchy. So the
information of every error goes to
the value node up the hierarchy and
basically tells it to correct itself to
change the prediction.
So to perform a correlation using
predictive coding, what you have to do
is that you take an observation and you
simply fix the value of a specific
neuron. So if you want to compute the
probability of x four given x three
equal to s three, we simply have to take
x three and fix it to s three in a way
that it doesn't change anymore and run
an energy minimization. And this model,
by updating the axis via
a minimization of the variational free
energy allows the model to converge to a
solution to this question. So the
probability or the expected value of x
four given x three equals three.
But how do I perform an intervention now
without acting on the structure of the
graph? Well, this is basically the
first idea of the paper, this is still
how to perform a correlation. So fix s
three equal to x three is the first step
in the algorithm and the second one is
to obtain the axis by minimizing the
variation of free energy,
an intervention which in theory
corresponds in removing those arrows and
answers to the question the probability
of x four by performing an intervention.
So do x three equal s three? Imperative
coding can be performed as follows.
So I'm going to write the algorithm
here. So first, as in a correlation,
you fix s three equal equal to the you
fix x three equal to the observation
that you get then this is the important
step. You have to intervene not on the
graph anymore, but on the prediction
error and fix it equal to zero.
Having a prediction error equal to zero
basically sends
meaningless information up the
hierarchy, or actually sends no
information up the hierarchy because it
basically tells you that the prediction
is always correct. And the third
step is to, as we did before, to update
the axis, the unconstrained axis. So x
one, x two, x four. By minimizing the
variation of free energy, as I will show
now experimentally, by simply doing this
little trick of setting a prediction
error to be equal to zero,
it prevents us to actually act on the
structure of the graph, as the theory
of Ducalculus does, and to infer the
missing the variables after an
intervention. By simply performing
aberration of free energy minimization.
What about counterfactual inference?
Counterfactual inference is actually
easy once we have defined
how to do an intervention. And this
is because as we saw earlier,
performing a counterfactual is similar
to performing an intervention in a past
situation after you have inferred the
unobservable variables. So,
as you can see in the plot I showed
earlier about the abduction action and
prediction steps, the action and
prediction steps, they did not have
those two arrows, they were removed.
Pretty coding allows allow us to keep
the arrows in the graph
and perform counterfactuals by simply
performing an adoption step, as it was
done earlier, an action step in which we
simply perform an intervention on the
single node. So we fix the value node
and we set the error to zero and
run the energy minimization. So
minimizing the rational free energy to
compute the prediction.
So, I think this is like an easy
and elegant method to perform
interventions at counterfactuals.
I think the thing we have to show now is
whether it works in practice or not.
And we have a couple of experiments and
I'm going to show you now two different
experiments. The first one is merely
proof of concept experiment that shows
that the operative coding is able to
perform intervention and
counterfactuals. And the second
one actually shows a simple application
in how interventional queries can be
used to improve the performance of
classification tasks on a specific kind
of predictive coding networks, which is
that of a fully connected model. Let's
start from the first one. So how do we
do this task? So, given a structural
causal model, we generate training data
and we use it to learn the weights. So,
to learn the functions of the structural
causal models,
and then we generate test data for both
interventional and counterfactual
queries and we show whether we are able
to converge to the correct test data
using predictive coding.
For example, here those two plots
represent intervention and
counterfactual queries of this specific
graph, which is the butterfly bias
graph, which is a graph that is often
used in in testing whether causal
inference, whether intervention and
counterfactual techniques work is as
simple as that. But in the paper you can
find a lot of different graphs. But in
general those two plots show that the
method works show that the
mean absolute error between the
interventional and counterfactual
quantities we compute and the
quantities from the original graph are
close to each other. So the error is
quite small. The second experiment
is basically an extension of an
experiment I proposed in an earlier
paper which is the Learning on arbitrary
graph topologies that I wrote last year.
In that paper, I basically proposed
this kind of network as a proof of
concept, which is a fully connected
network, which is, in general, the worst
neural network you can have to perform
machine learning experiments because
given a fixed set of neurons,
basically every
pair of neuron is connected by two
different synapses. So is
the model with the highest complexity
possible in general. The good thing is
that since you have a lot of cycles,
the model is extremely flexible in the
sense that you can train it, for
example, on a Minced image and on a data
point and on its label. But then the way
you can query it, thanks to the
information going back, is you can
query in a lot of different ways. So you
can perform classification tasks in
which you provide an image and you run
the energy minimization and get the
label but you can also, for example,
perform generation tasks in which you
give the label, run the Energy
Minimization and get the image. You can
perform, for example, image completion
in which you give half the image and
let the model convert to the second half
and so forth and so on. So it's
basically a model that learns the
statistics of the data set in its
entirety without being focused on
classification or generation in general.
So this flexibility is great. The
problem is that because of this every
single task doesn't work well so it can
do a lot of different things but none of
them is done well and here
I want to show how using interventional
queries instead of standard
correlational queries or conditional
queries slightly improves the results of
those classification tasks. So what are
the conjecture reasons of the test
accuracy on those tasks not
being so high? The two reasons are that
the model is distracted in correcting
every single error. So basically you
present an image and you would like to
get a label but the model is actually
updating itself to also predict the
error in the images and the second
reason, which is the one I said, is that
the structure is far too complex.
So again, from an OCAM
razor argumentation this is the worst
model you can have. So every time you
have a model that. Fits a data set.
That model is going to be less complex
than this one that is going to be
preferred, but in general just to
study it, the idea is can query in this
model be interventions be used to
improve the performance of those fully
connected models? Well, the answer is
yes. So here is how I perform
interventional queries. So I present an
image to the network, I fix the error of
the pixels to be equal to zero so this
error doesn't get propagated in the
network. And then I compute the label
and as you can see the accuracy
improves. For example, from 89 using the
standard query method of creative coding
networks, to 92, which is the accuracy
after the intervention. And the same
happens for fashion minced.
And I think that a very legit critique
that probably everyone would think when
seeing those plots is that okay, you
improved on mins from 89 to 92.
It still sucks basically. And yeah,
it's true. And actually in the later
slides I'm going to show how to act on
the structure of this fully connected
model will improve the results even more
until the point they reach a performance
that is not even close to state of the
art performance of course,
but up to a level that becomes visually
acceptable and worth investigating.
Yes. So this was the part about causal
inference using previous coding.
And I guess to summarize, I can say that
the interesting part of the results
I just showed is that I showed that
predictive coding is able to perform
interventions in a very easy and
intuitive way because you don't have to
act on the structure of the old graph
anymore. Sometimes those functions are
not available, so forth and so on. But
you simply have to intervene on a single
neuron, set its prediction error to zero
and perform an energy minimization
process. And this extended
allowed us to define predictive coding
based structural causal models. Now we
move to the second part of the
work which is about structure learning.
So structure learning, as I said, deals
with the problem of learning the causal
structure of the model from
observational data. This is actually an
old problem that has been around for
decades and
has always been until a couple of years
ago tackled using combinatorial search
methods. The problem with those
combinatorial search methods is that
their complexity grows double
exponentially. So as soon as the data
becomes multidimensional and the
Bayesian graph that you want to learn
grows in size learning, it it's
incredibly slow. The new solution
that came out actually a couple of years
ago in a new research paper from 2018
showed that it's possible to actually
learn this structure not using a
combinatorial search method, but by
using a gradient based method. And this
killed the problem in general because
now you can simply have a prior on the
parameters, which is the prior the
proposed that I'm going to define a
little bit better in this slide run
gradient descent. And even if you have a
model that is double triple the size,
the algorithm is still incredibly fast.
And for this reason this paper is I
think it's kind of new and I think
already has around 600 citations or
things like that. And every paper that
I'm seeing now about causal inference
and learning causal structure of the
graph uses their method. It just changes
a little bit. They find faster or
slightly better inference methods, but
still they all use the prior this paper
defined and I do as well, and we do as
well. So here we define
a new quantity which is the agency
matrix. The agency matrix is simply a
matrix that encodes the connections of
the model. So it's a binary matrix and
in general it's a binary matrix. Then of
course, when you do gradient based
optimization you make it continuous and
then you have some threshold at some
point that basically kills an edge or
set it to one and the entry IJ
is equal to one if
the Bayesian graph has an edge from
vertex I to vertex j or zero otherwise.
So for example, this agency matrix here
represents the connectivity structure of
this Bayesian network.
And basically this method tackles
two problems that we want about learning
the structure of the Bayesian network.
The idea is that we start from a fully
connected model, which conceptually is
similar, actually is equivalent to the
creative coding network I defined
earlier, which is fully connected. So
you have a lot of vertices and every
pair of vertices is connected by two
different edges and you simply want to
prune the ones that are not needed.
So it can be seen as a method that
performs model reduction. You start from
a big model and you want to make it
small. So what's the first ingredient to
reduce models? Well, it's of course
sparse city. And what's the prior that
everyone uses to make a model more
sparse is the LaPlace prior, which in
machine learning is simply known as the
L one norm, which is defined here.
The solution that this paper that I
mentioned earlier proposed is to add a
second prior on top, which enforces
what's probably the biggest
characteristic of Bayesian networks on
which you want to perform causal
inference is that you want them to be a
cyclic. And basically they show that
Acyclicity can be imposed on an agency
matrix as a prior and it has this shape
here. So it's the trace of the matrix
that is the exponential
of a times a where A is the agency
matrix again. And basically this
quantity here is equal to zero if and
only if the Bayesian network or
whatever graph you're considering is a
cyclic.
So I'm going to use this in some
experiments. So to force those two
priors on different kinds of
Bayesian networks and I'm trying to
merge them with the techniques we
proposed earlier about performing causal
inference via predictive coding. So I'm
going to present two different
experiments. So one is a proof of
concept, which is the standard
experiments showed in all the structural
learning tasks, which is the inference
of the correct Bayesian network from
data. And then I'm going to build on top
of the classification experiments I
showed earlier and show how
actually those priors allow us to
improve the classification accuracy,
the test accuracy of fully connected
predictive coding models.
So let's move to the first experiment,
which is to infer the structure of the
graph. And the experiments, they all
follow basically the same pipeline in
all the papers in the field. The first
step is to generate a vision network
from a random graph. So basically,
normally the two random graphs that
everyone tests are erdos reni graphs and
scale free graph. So you generate those
big graphs that normally have 20, 40,
80 different nodes and some edges that
you sample randomly and you use this
graph to generate a data set. So you
sample, for example, n, big N data
points. And what you do is that you take
the graph they have generated earlier
and you throw it away. You only keep the
data set. And the task you want to solve
now is to
have a training algorithm that basically
allows you to retrieve
the structure of the graph you have
thrown away. So the way we do it here
is that we train a fully connected
creative coding model on this data set D
using both the sparse and the acyclic
priors we have defined earlier and see
whether actually the graph that we
converge to after pruning away.
The entries of the agency matrix that
are smaller than a certain threshold is
similar to that of the of the initial
graph. And the results show that this
is actually the case. So this is an
example and I show many different
parameterization and dimensions and
things like that in the paper, but I
think those two are the most
representative examples with an Ernest
Sharoni graph and a free scale graph
with 20 nodes. And here
on the left you can see the ground truth
graph, which is the one sampled
randomly. And on the right you can see
the graph the predictive coding model
has learned from the data set. And as
you can see, they are quite similar.
It's still not perfect, so there are
some errors, but in general the
structure is they work quite well. We
also have some quantitative experiments
that I don't show here because they're
just huge tables with a lot of numbers
and I thought it was maybe a little bit
too much for the presentation, but the
results show that they perform similarly
to contemporary methods. Also because
I have to say, like, most of the quality
comes from the Acyclic prior that was
introduced in 2018.
The second class of experiments are
classification experiments, which as I
said are the extensions of the one I
shared earlier. And the idea is to use
structure learning to improve the
classification on the classification
results on the means and fashion means
data set, starting from a fully
connected graph. So, what I
did is that I divided the fully
connected graph in clusters of neurons.
So one big cluster is the
one related to the input and all the
small. Then we have some a specific
number of hidden clusters.
And then we have the label cluster,
which is the cluster of neurons that
are supposed to give me the label
predictions. And I've trained
them using the first time, the sparse
prior only. See, the idea is what if I,
if I prune the connections I don't need
from a model and learn a sparser model?
Does this work? Well, the answer is no,
it doesn't work. And the reason why is
that at the end, the graph that you
converge with is actually the generate.
So basically the model learns to predict
the label based on the label itself. So
it discards all the information from the
input and only keeps the label. And as
you can see here, the label y predicts
itself. Or in other experiments, when
you change the parameters, you have that
y predicts x zero that predicts x one
that predicts y again. So what's
the solution to this problem? Well, the
solution to this problem is that we have
to converge to an acyclic graph
and so we have to add something that
prevents acyclicity. And what is that
one is of course, the one I already
proposed. And then I show a second
technique. So the first one uses
the acyclic prior defined earlier.
And the second one is a novel technique
that actually makes use of negative
examples. So a negative example in this
case is simply a data point in which
you have an image, but the label is
wrong. So here, for example, you have an
image of a seven, but the label that I'm
giving the model is a two.
The idea is very simple, has been used
in a lot of works already. So every
time the model sees a positive example,
it has to increase to minimize the
variation of free energy. And every time
it sees a negative example, it has to
increase it. So we want this quantity
to be minimized.
And actually, with a lot of experiments
and a lot of experimentations, we saw
that the two techniques basically first
lead to the same results and second lead
to the same graph as well. So here
are the new results on Minced and
fashion Mins using the two techniques
that I just proposed. And now we
move to some which are still not great,
but still definitely more reasonable
test accuracies. So here we have a test
error of 3.17 for Minced and a test
error of 13.98 for Fashion Minced. And
actually those results can be much
improved by learning the structure of
the graph on Minced and then
fixing the structure of the graph and do
some form of fine tuning. So if you fine
tune the model on the correct
hierarchical structure, at some point
you reach the test accuracy, which is
the one you would expect from a
hierarchical model, but those ones are
simply the one the fully connected model
has naturally converged to.
For example, from a test error of 18.32
of the fully connected model train on
fashion means by simply performing
correlations or conditional queries,
which is the standard way of querying
Abrative coding model. Adding
interventions and the Acyclic prior
together makes this test
error much lower and we can observe it
for Mins as well.
I'm now going a little bit into details
on this last experiment and on how the
Acyclic prior acts on the structure of
the graph. I perform an experiment
on a new data set, which is, I mean,
calling it a new data set is maybe too
much. I called it a two means data set
in which you have the input point is
formed of two different images and the
label only depends on the second image,
on the first image. Sorry. So the idea
here is, is the structure of the model,
the Acyclicity prior and things like
that, able to recognize that the second
half of the image is actually
meaningless in
learning, in performing classification,
how does training behave in general?
Like, for example, we have this input
node output node and only the nodes are
fully connected. Can the model converge
to a hierarchical structure, which is
the one that we know performs the best
on classification tasks? Well, here is
an example of a training method of a
training run. So at c zero, which is the
beginning of training, we have this
model here. So S zero corresponds to the
seven. So to the first image, s one
corresponds to the seven image. Again,
we have the label y and all the latent
variables x zero, x one, x two. And the
model is fully connected. So the agency
matrix is full of ones. There are
no zeros. We have self loops and things
like that. We train the model
for a couple of epochs until and what
we note immediately is that, for
example, the model immediately
understands that the four is not needed
to perform classification.
So every outgoing node from
the second input cluster is removed.
And something that you understand is
that this cluster is the one related to
the output. So we have
a linear map from s zero to y directly,
which is this part here. But we know
that actually a linear map is not the
best map for performing classification
on Minst. So we need some hierarchy, we
need some depth to improve the results.
And as you can see, this line here is
the accuracy which up to this point, so
up to c two is similar to is
91% which is slightly better than linear
classification. But once you go on with
the training, the model understands that
it needs some hierarchy to better fit
the data. So you see that this arrow
starts getting stronger and stronger
over time until it understands
that the linear map is not actually
really needed and it removes it.
So the model you converge with is a
model that starts from a zero, goes to a
hidden node, and then goes to the label
with a very weak linear map, which
actually gets removed if you set a
threshold. Of if you set a threshold of,
for example, 0.10.2, at some point the
linear map gets forgotten and everything
you end up with is with a hierarchical
network. So it
has learned the correct structure to
perform classification tasks, which is
hierarchy. And it has also learned that
the second image didn't play any role in
defining the test accuracy. And this
is all performed, so all those jobs are
simply performed by one
free energy minimization process. So you
initialize the model, you define the
free energy, you define the priors. So
the sparse and the cyclic prior, you run
the energy minimization and you converge
to a hierarchical model which is well
able to perform classification on minst.
And then if you then perform some fine
tuning, you reach very competitive
results as you do in feed forward
networks with backpropagation. But I
think that's not the interesting bit.
The interesting bit is that all this
process altogether of intervention and a
cyclicity allows you to take a fully
connected network and converge to a
hierarchical one that is able to perform
classification with good results.
And yeah, that's basically it.
Wow, I've talked a lot and this is the
conclusion of the talk, which is I'm
basically doing a small summary and I
think the important takeaway, if I have
to give you in one sentence of this
paper, is that predictive coding is a
belief updating method that is able to
perform end to end causal learning. So
it's able to perform interventions to
learn a structure from data and then
perform interventions and
counterfactuals.
So causal inference in natural and
efficiently model interventions by
simply setting the prediction error to
zero. So it's a very easy technique to
perform interventions and you only have
to touch one neuron. You don't have to
act on the structure of the graph,
you can use it to create structure
causal models that are biologically
plausible. It is able to learn the
structure from data, as I said, maybe a
lot of times already and
a couple of sentences about future works
is that something that would be nice
to do is to improve the performance of
the model we have defined. Because I
think it performs reasonably well on a
lot of tasks. So it performs reasonably
well on structured learning, on forming
intervention and counterfactuals. But
actually, if you look at state of the
art model, there's always like a very
specific method that performs better in
the single task. So it would be
interesting to see if we can reach those
level of performance in specific tasks
by adding some tricks or
some new optimization methods and to
generalize it to dynamical systems which
are actually much more interesting the
static systems such as dynamical causal
models or other techniques that allow
you to perform causal inference in
systems that move. So an action taken in
a specific time step influences another
node in a later time step, which is
basically granger causality.
Yeah, that's it. And thank
you very much.
Thank you. Awesome and very
comprehensive presentation. That was
really I think you're muted.
Sorry, muted on zoom. But yes, thanks
for the awesome and very comprehensive
presentation. There was really a lot
there, and there was also a lot of great
questions in the live chat. So maybe to
warm into the questions, how did you
come to study this topic? Were you
studying causality and found predictive
coding to be useful or vice versa? Or
how did you come at this intersection?
Actually, I have to say that the first
person that came out with this idea was
Baron,
I think a year and a half ago, even
more, he brought a page with this idea
and then it got forgotten and no one
picked it up. And last summer I started
getting curious about causality and I
read, for example, the Book of Why,
after listening to podcasts, the
standard way in which you get interested
in a topic. And I remember this idea
from Baron and proposed it to him, and I
was like, why don't we expand it and
actually make it a paper? So I involved
some people to help me with experiments,
and this is the final result at the end.
Awesome. Cool. Yeah, a lot to
say. I'm just going to go to the live
chat first and address a bunch of
different questions. And if anybody else
wants to add. I'm going to turn the
light on first because I think I'm
getting in the dark more and more. Yes.
Who said active inference can't solve
the dark room issue? Oh, yes, here we
are. So would you say the light switch
caused it to be lighter?
Yeah, I think so. No issues
here. Okay. ML. Don wrote,
since in predictive coding all
distributions are usually Gaussian, the
bottom up messages are precision
weighted prediction errors, where
precision is the inverse of the Gaussian
covariance. What if non Gaussian
distributions are used?
Basically, the general method stays.
The main difference is that you don't
have prediction errors, which, as was
correctly pointed out, is basically the
derivative of the variation of free
energy. If you have Gaussian assumptions
yeah. You don't have that single
quantity to set to zero and you probably
will have to act on the structure of the
graph to perform interventions.
And also, you and colleagues had a paper
in 2022 predictive coding beyond
gaussian distributions that looked at
some of these issues, right? Yes,
exactly. So that paper was a little bit
the idea behind that paper is can we
model transformers? That's the biggest
motivation using predictive coding. And
the answer is no, because the attention
mechanisms are softmax at the end and
softmax calls not to
Gaussian distribution, but to softmax
distribution. I don't get the name now,
but yes. So yes, that's a
generalization. It's a little bit tricky
to call it once you remove the Gaussian
assumption, it's a little bit still
tricky to call it predictive coding.
For example, like talking to Karl
Friedston, predictive coding is only
if you have only Gaussian assumptions.
But yes, that's more a philosophical
debate than.
Interesting. Another, I think topic
that's definitely of great interest is
similarities and differences between the
attention apparatus in Transformers and
the way that attention is described from
a neurocognitive perspective and from a
predictive processing precision
weighting angle. What do you think about
that? Well, the idea is
that I think about it is that
from a predictive processing and also
vocational inference perspective,
attention can be seen as a kind of
structured learning problem. I think
there's a recent paper from Chris
Buckley's group that shows that there
should be a reprint on Archive in which
basically they showed that the attention
mechanism is simply learning the
precision on the weight parameters
specific to a data point. So this
precision is not a parameter that is in
the structure of the model. So it's not
a model specific parameter, but it's a
fast changing parameter like the value
nodes that gets updated while minimizing
the vibrational free energy. And once
you have minimized it and computed,
then you throw it away and from the next
data point you have to recompute it from
scratch. So yes, I think the analogy
computation wise is the attention
mechanism can be seen as a kind of
structured learning, but a structured
learning that is data point specific and
not model specific. And I think if you
want to generalize a little bit and go
from the attention mechanism in
transformers to the attention mechanism,
cognitive science, I feel they're
probably too different to draw
similarities. And I think the structured
learning analogy and how important one
connection is with respect to another
one probably does the job much better.
Cool. Great answer. Okay,
ML Don asks in counterfactuals
what is the difference between hidden
variables X and unobserved variables U?
The difference is that I
think the main one is that you cannot
observe the use. You can use them
because you can compute them and fix
them, but the idea is that you have no
control over them. So the use should be
seen as environment specific variables
that they are there, they influence your
process because for example, when you
go back in time, the environment is
different. So the idea is, for example,
if you like going back to the example
before of the expected income of a
person with a specific intelligence of
education degree. The idea is that if I
want to see how much I will earn today
with a master degree is different with
respect to how much I would earn 20
years ago with a master degree is
different. For example, here in Italy
with respect to other countries and all
those variables that are not under your
control. You cannot model them using
your Bayesian network, but they are
there. Okay. So you cannot ignore them
when you want to draw conclusions. So,
yeah, it's basically everything that you
cannot control, you can infer them.
So you can perform a counterfactual
inference back in time and say, oh, 20
years ago, I would have earned this much
if I was this intelligent at this
degree, on average, of course. But it's
not that I can change the government
policies towards jobs or things
like that. It's a deeper counterfactual.
Yes, exactly. So those are the use.
Awesome. All right. Have you implemented
generalized coordinates in predictive
coding? No,
I've never done it. I've studied
it, but I've never implemented it. I
know they tend to be unstable,
and it's very hard to make them stable.
I think that's the takeaway that I got
from talking to people that have
implemented them.
But yeah, I'm aware of some papers that
came out, actually recently about them
that tested on some bracelet, encoder
style, actually, I think still from
Baron. There's a paper out there that
came out last summer. But no, I've never
played them with them myself. Cool.
From Bert. Does adding more levels in
the hierarchy reduce the distraction
problem of predicting input?
Adding more level, in which sense
because the distraction problem is given
by cycles. So basically you provide an
image, and the fact that you have edges
going out of the image going in the
neurons, and then other edges going
back, this basically creates the fact
that basically
these ingoing edges to the pixels of the
image, they create some prediction
errors. So you have some prediction
errors that get spread inside the model.
And this problem, I think, is general of
cycles, and it's probably not related to
hierarchy in general,
is the two incoming edges to the pixels.
If you don't have incoming edges, you
have no destruction problem anymore.
Cool. And the specification of the
asyclic network through the trace
operator, that's a very interesting
technique. And when was that brought
into play?
As far as I know, I think it came out
with a paper I cited in 2018. I don't
know, at least in the causal inference
literature. I'm not aware of any
previous methods. I would say no,
because that's the highly cited paper.
So I would say they came out with that
idea. Wow. But yeah, that's quite nice
that you can do gradient descent and
learn the structure. I think that's a
very powerful technique. Yeah,
sometimes it's like when you look at
when different features of Bayesian
inference and causal inference became
available. It's really remarkable.
Why hasn't this been done under a
Bayesian causal modeling framework?
It's like because there's only been like
five to 25 years of this happening,
and so that's very short. And also it's
relatively technical, so there's
relatively few research groups engaging
in it. And it's just really cool what
it's enabling. Yes, exactly. I mean,
that's also, I think, the exciting part
of this field a little bit that is, I
mean, there are definitely breakthroughs
out there that still have to be
discovered and probably because, for
example, for as much as a breakthrough
that paper was,
they simply found the right prior for
acyclic structures. Okay,
yeah, I don't know exactly, but it may
be an idea that you have in one
afternoon. I don't know about the story
of how the authors came up with that,
but could potentially be that they're
there at the whiteboard. You're like,
oh, that actually works. That's a huge
breakthrough. And I simply defined the
prior. And also, a lot of these
breakthroughs, they don't just stack.
It's not like a tower of
blocks. They layer and they compose.
So then something will be generalized to
generalized coordinates or generalized
synchrony, or arbitrarily large graphs
or sensor fusion with multimodal inputs.
And it's like those all blend in really
satisfying and effective ways. So even
little things that, again, someone can
just come up with in a moment can really
have impact.
Okay, ML. Don says, thanks a lot for
asking my questions, and thanks a
million to Tomaso for the inspiring
presentation. So nice. Thank you very
much. And then Bert asks, how would
language models using predictive coding
differ from those using transformers?
Okay, I think that actually, if I would
have to build today a language model
using predictive coding, I would still
use transformers. So the idea is that,
for example, if you have, let's say,
this hierarchical graphical model or
this hierarchical Bayesian network,
I've defined in the very first slides
one arrow to encode a function, which is
the linear map. Okay? So one arrow was
simply the multiplication of the vector
encoded in the latent variables times
this weight matrix that you can then
make nonlinear and things like that.
But that can be actually something much
more complex. The function encoded in
the arrow can be a convolution, can be
an attention. So actually,
how I would do it, I will still use the
which is actually the way we did it in
the Oxford group last year, is that we
had exactly the structure. Every arrow
is a transformer now. So one is the
attention mechanism and the next one is
the feed forward network. As
transformers. Basically, the only
difference that you have is that those
variables, you want to compute the
posterior and you make those posteriors
independent via minfield approximation.
So basically, you follow all the steps
that allow you to converge to the
variation of. Free energy of creative
coding. But the way you compute
predictions and the way you send signals
back is done via transformer.
So I will still use transformers in
general. I mean, they work so well that
I don't think that we can be arrogant
and say, oh no, I'm going to do it
better via a purely predictive coding
way. Structure learning is a way, but
will still approximate transformers
anyway. Sorry, you said structured
learning would approximate the
transformer approach. Yes, the structure
learning I mentioned earlier when
someone asked the similarities between
creative coding and the attention
mechanism.
Yeah, very interesting.
One thing I am wondering from ML Don, I
could not see the concept of depth in
the predictive coding networks you
mentioned. Most likely I missed it. The
definition provided for predictive
coding involved the concept of depth.
What did you mean by depth? No. Yes,
it's true because the standard
definition, as I said multiple times,
is hierarchical. You have predictions
going one direction and prediction error
going the opposite direction.
Basically, what we did in this
paper and also in the last one, which is
called learning on arbitrary graph
topologies via rated coding, is that we
can consider depth as
independent, basically pair of
latent variable, latent variable and
arrow. And you have predictions going
that direction and prediction arrow
going the other. But then you can
compose these in a lot of ways.
So basically this composition doesn't
have to be hierarchical in the end, can
have cycles. So then you can, for
example, plug in another latent variable
to the first one and then connect the
other two. And you can have a structure
that is as entangled as you want. So,
for example, in the other paper, we
trained a network that has the shape of
a brain structure. So we have a lot of
brain regions that are sparsely
connected inside and sparsely connected
among each other. And there's nothing
hierarchical there at the end. But you
can still train it by minimizing
abbreviation of free energy and by
minimizing the total prediction error of
the network. So you
could have for a given motif in
an entangled graph, you might see three
successive layers that when you looked
at them alone, you'd say, oh, that's a
three story building. That's a three
layer model that has a depth of three.
But then when you take a bigger picture,
there isn't like an explicit top or an
explicit bottom to that network.
Yes, exactly. And this is basically
given by the fact that every operation
in predictive coding networks is
strictly local. So basically every
message passing, every prediction and
every prediction error that you send,
you only send it to the very nearby
neurons. Okay? And whether the global
structure is actually hierarchical or
not, the single message passing doesn't
even see that. I guess that's
sort of the hope for learning.
New model architectures is
the space of what is designed.
Top down is very small and
a lot of models in use today, albeit
super effective models,
although you could ask effective per
unit of compute or not, that's a second
level question. But a lot of effective
models today do not have some of these
properties of predictive coding networks
like their capacity to use only local
computations which gives biological
realism or just spatiotemporal
realism, but also may provide a lot of
advantages in federated compute or
distributed computing settings. No?
Yes, exactly. I completely agree. I
think the idea in general is that and I
don't know if that's going to be an
advantage, I think it's very promising
exactly for the reasons you said. And
the reason is that today's models
trained with backpropagation, you can
basically summarize them as
a model train with backpropagation is a
function because basically you have a
map from input to output and
backpropagation basically spreads
information back from its computational
graph. So every neural network model
used today is a function while
predictive coding and other liberative
coding, like the old class of functions,
class of methods that train using local
computations and actually work by
minimizing a global energy function.
They're not limited to model functions
from input to output. They actually
model something that kind of resembles
physical systems. So you have a physical
system, you fix some values to whatever
input you have and you let the system
converge and then you read some other
neurons or variables that are supposed
to be output. But this physical system
doesn't have to be a fit forward map,
doesn't have to be a function that has
an input space and an output space and
that's it. So the class of models that
you can learn so basically you can see
like feed forward models and functions
and then a much bigger class which is
that of physical systems. Whether
there's something interesting out here,
I don't know yet because the functions
are working extremely well. We are
seeing those days with back propagation.
They work crazy well. I don't know if
there's anything interesting in the big
part, but the big part is quite big.
Okay. There are a lot of models that you
cannot train with back propagation and
you can train with creative coding or.
Evidence propagation or other methods
that is super interesting. Certainly
biological systems, physical systems
solve all kinds of interesting problems,
but there's still no free lunch. An ant
species that does really well in this
environment might not do very well in
another environment. And so out there in
the hinterlands there might be some
really unique special algorithms
that are not well described by being a
function yet still provide
like a procedural way to implement
Heuristics which might be extremely,
extremely effective. No?
Yes, exactly. And I think this has been
most of my focus of research during my
PhD. For example, like finding this
application that is like out here and
not inside the functions.
Cool. Well, where does this work
go from here, like what directions are
you excited about and how do you see
people in the octave inference ecosystem
getting involved in this type of work.
I think probably the most promising
direction, which is something maybe
I would like to explore a little bit,
is to, as I said earlier, is to go
behind statical models. So everything
I've shown so far is about static
data. So the data don't change over
time. There's no time inside the
definition of creative coding as it is,
as I presented it here. However, you
can, for example, generalize creative
coding to work with temporal data using
generalized coordinates, as you
mentioned earlier, by presenting
it as a Kalman filter generative model.
And that's where, for example, the
causal inference direction could be very
useful because at that point
maybe you can be able to model greater
causality and more complex and
useful dynamical causal models,
basically because in general, the
Ducalculus and interventional and
counterfactual branch of science is
mostly developed on small models.
You don't do interventions on gigantic
models in general. So if you look at
medical data, they use relatively small
Bayesian networks. But of course, if you
want to have a dynamical causal model
that models a specific environment or a
specific reality, you have a lot of
neurons inside, you have a lot of latent
variables, they change over time and an
intervention at some moment creates an
effect in a different time step. So
maybe in the next time step in ten
different time steps later. And I think
that would be very interesting to
develop like a biologically plausible
way of passing information that is also
able to model grandeur causality.
Basically.
Where do you see action in these models?
Where do I see action?
I didn't think of that. I think
I see actions in those models maybe in
the same way as you see in other models
because creative coding is basically a
model of perception. So an action is
you can see it as a consequence of what
you are experiencing. So by changing
the way you're experiencing something,
then you can compute, maybe you can
simply perform as smarter actions now
that you have more information.
But yeah, I don't think action is very I
don't see any explicit consequence of
actions besides the fact that this can
allow you to basically maybe to simply
draw better conclusions to then perform
actions in the future. I'll add
on to that a few ways that people have
talked about predictive coding and
action. First off, internal action or
covert action is attention. So we can
think about perception as an internal
action. That's one approach. Another
approach, pretty micro, is the outputs
of a given node. We could understand
that node as a particular thing with its
own sensory, cognitive and action
states. And so in that sense, the output
of a node. And then lastly, which we
explored a little bit in Live Stream 43
on the theoretical review on predictive
coding. We were reading all the way
through, and it was all about
perception. All about perception. And
then it was like Section 5.3 if you have
expectations about action, then action
is just another variable in this
architecture. And that's really aligned
with inactive inference, where instead
of having, like, a reward or utility
function that we maximize, we select
action based upon it being the,
likeliest, course of action, the path of
least action. That's Bayesian Mechanics.
And so it's actually very natural to
bring in an action variable and utilize
it essentially as if it were a
prediction about something else
exterceptibly in the world. Because
we're also expecting action. No.
Yes, exactly. No. I like the way of
defining actions a lot, actually. And I
still think it has been, like, for
example, there are not so many papers
that apply this method. I think there
are a couple from Alexander Orobria does
something similar, but in, like,
outside of the pure active inference,
like, applying predictive coding and
actions to solve practical problems
hasn't been explored a lot.
Cool. Well, thank you for this excellent
presentation and discussion. Is there
anything else that you want to say or
point people towards? No,
just a big thank you for inviting me,
and it was really fun, and I hope to
come back at some point for some future.
Anytime. Anytime. Thank you, Thomas.
Thank you. Daniel. See you. Bye.